[Music]
okay
[Music]
let's let's cover this before we delve
into more i had a number of people in my
audience ask about joe rogan because
apparently there's something going on
with you and joe rogan so can you give a
bit of a background about what that's
about and what happened sure
something like seven years ago
i went on the joe rogan show three times
and
uh in fact i'll post something on
instagram
because you can't see it joe pulled it
off of spotify he's been trying to hide
this
and
uh bulletproof coffee changes brain for
the better i mean he's worn the
bulletproof t-shirt on on there and was
just a huge fan and i uh and he's like
damn oh my goodness grass-fed beef this
is so important
i love all this
but then one of his buddies decided to
try to steal
both the name bulletproof as well as
my ideas and one of the companies he
owns decided to try to steal and copy my
products and the day they made that
decision
he made up some stuff around uh around
me
as well as
some fake tests that have never existed
as far as i can tell saying that my
coffee was moldy guys i've spent way
more than a hundred thousand dollars on
lab tests over the years the bulletproof
coffee that i created is lab tested to
the highest possible standards
but he basically tried to discredit me
for quite a while it looks like it was
partly financially motivated and partly
probably one of his buddies manipulating
him
and so i i learned a lot
about bullying and what bullies do when
they grow up
it was it was rough because i'm like i'm
helping people i'm i'm motivated by not
letting people get to 300 pounds like i
did and just not have brain fog and i
know the kind of suffering out there and
it went from dave thanks for all of your
advice to you know you're a charlatan
snake oil salesman because like there's
about 20 000 trolls the the death squad
guys
and literally they stick them on me so
all of a sudden my social media just
went all to hell overnight like wow
this is kind of freaking me out and i
didn't really know how to take it so i
did some of the weird personal
development stuff that i do and and i
just realized after a little while every
time joe says something bad about me i'm
selling more coffee
even though like it kind of hurts
and i just realized i didn't do anything
wrong i i did everything at the highest
integrity uh and what's cool is
uh now that joe's pulled those things
down there's fair use exemptions so i
put together a compilation of all the
things joe's said and like you can try
and reel it back by deleting it but
bottom line is i'm pretty sure that
there's a reason the companies that joe
owns are starting to sell mct oil and
trying to copy the coffee they just
couldn't do the mold free thing so we
tried to say it wasn't real and i would
challenge anyone who thinks it's not
real to just read what i write
damn okay
that's spicy
joe thank you brother i appreciate all
the sales i appreciate you i appreciate
all the stuff you're doing in the world
and uh i don't feel bad for not getting
high before i was interviewed on your
show because i just sounded like a total
idiot
[Music]